on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight sensor one of the most infamous
men in the world Andrew Tate's
misogynistic tirades have been viewed
billions of Times online he's now been
effectively banned though from the
internet he doesn't think that's fair
tonight I'm going to try and work out if
it is
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from London and welcome to
special edition of Piers Morgan
uncensored Andrew Tate one on one
he's the most famous man you probably
never heard of with billions of views
online at one point this year more
people were searching Google for Andrew
Tate and Donald Trump or Kim Kardashian
former professional kickboxer he was
kicked off big brother in 2016 after a
video emerged of him striking a woman
and what they now both claimed was the
consensual sex game he since made
Millions as a pornographer and casino
owner in Romania but it's his online
videos that have made him notorious
across the world posing as a Playboy
with fast cars cigars weapons and cash
he rant about his often scandalous views
on women or instruct a female to provide
sustenance
cool so I think my sister is my her
husband's property yes tell young men
they can get as rich as him by paying
for his digital life lessons
I have a hundred
bit I'm going to teach
which will allow you
to own money in
class the net has clothes on Andrew Tate
while Millions still share his videos
it's effectively banned from the web
booted off Facebook YouTube Instagram
Twitter and Tick Tock so his fans is a
misunderstood satirist and the victim of
big Tech censorship to many others he's
a malicious misogynist tonight I'll try
and get to the truth
well some of the opinions Andrew Tate
says in his videos are undeniably deeply
offensive we're going to show you some
of them on this show I think you should
see them for yourself not simply hear
what he says about them or what other
people say about them tens of millions
of people across the world follow Andrew
Tate and where the big Following comes a
big responsibility as well as a public
interest in holding his views to account
if outrageous opinions are read aloud
they can be challenged and exposed for
what they are they're silenced the
person holding these views can become a
martyr so that's why I invited Andrew
Tate to come here tonight and he joins
me now live so Andrew well welcome first
of all
um you come all the way from Romania to
do this interview correct what do you
hope to achieve from this interview why
are you here it'd be interesting to have
a conversation with you you've certainly
been uh the subject of your own divided
opinions in the world uh there's a lot
of people who would say some of the
things you say are perhaps dangerous or
toxic so I thought you'd be a good
person to speak to about this subject I
didn't know much about you before this
year and then I suddenly became very
aware of you as the world did because as
I said earlier you you were the number
one subject searched on Google ahead of
Donald Trump I don't think it was even
possible why did you get suddenly so
popular stroke Infamous do you think I
exploded uh I certainly didn't do that
with magic I've been on the internet for
a very long time I think in the world we
live in now as the other side the other
side the people who disagree with me as
they get more and more tyrannical in
their censorships and their hate mobs
Etc as standard masculine practices are
deemed toxic I didn't put a magic spell
on everybody I managed to accumulate a
large amount of affinity with the male
populace Across the Western world
because I'm simply saying things that
many men believe think and feel the
problem I would say is I want to play
you just a clip off the top this is from
Joe Rogan he's somebody I absolutely
love sure and I think it explains to me
what my what I presume my issue with you
is going to be right correct and you you
have absolutely got the right to try and
persuade me otherwise sure but Joe Rogan
said this about you
my 12 year old and my 14 year old asked
me about Andrew Tate
I said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer I like him a lot why do you
like him and I was asking they said he
says a lot of funny stuff on on Twitter
and Tick Tock he [ __ ] up with the
misogynist yes because if he didn't do
that if he just said the pro mail stuff
so I thought that was interesting
because when I've gone over everything
that's been at the center of the debate
about Andrew Tate I come down with Joe
Rogan in the sense that there's a lot of
stuff you say I agree with you know I've
got three sons in my 20s it's not easy
actually being a young male in the
modern world
um and I think a lot of the things that
you say about that uh can resonate with
them the problem comes with the I don't
know 10 20 or whatever of your output
which on the face of it appears to be
blatant misogyny and when you couple
that with your massive influence and
huge reach that is why the social media
companies have decided to effectively
cancel you I don't believe in
cancellation I don't believe in
censorship particularly that's why I've
invited you to come on the show
um but I do think a lot of the things
you've said are blatant misogyny do you
accept that so you made a very
interesting point there you just said on
the face of it appear to be blatantly
misogynistic I understand that on the
face of some of the long format content
I've made Aid if you're going to take a
few seconds of hours chop it up put it
all over social media accompany with my
massive Fame then things can absolutely
not really be taken out of context I do
not hate women in any regard I have no
negative relationship with women no
women have come forward saying I've hurt
them I've no criminal record for hurting
women there's no way I can be seen as to
face or the devil in regards to how men
treat women on on the planet I'm
absolutely not really the opposite I
believe in protecting and providing I've
been misunderstood there's been large
contingents of people who have tried
very hard to purport lies about me and
and the the truth of the matter is I've
been producing content for a very long
time hours and hours of videos been cut
down to two or three seconds of clip
those clips have gone viral and people
misunderstand me I think you use this
phrase and be taken out of context and
I'm not I'm not sure that is correct in
the sense that it still comes out of
your mouth at some of the things
completely some of the things you've
said I just think are blatantly well
let's do let's do them well let's hear
them let's go through something sure
right so you said this about me too
stroke rate this is probably 40 of the
reason I moved to Romania in Eastern
Europe none of its garbage flies you go
to the police and say he raped me back
in 1988 they'll say well you should have
done something about it back then yeah
so the point I was making was obviously
at the height of the metoo Scandal and
also if we look at Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp there's been a lot of high
profile cases where men have been
accused of things they did not do
without evidence their lives have been
completely destroyed when I say these
things people sit and say that oh he
hates women I don't hate women I think
rape is disgusting I would take a
stronger stance on rape than the British
government I think these people should
face the death penalty but to sit and
say that women without evidence can go
forward and just make up accusations
against men even though they've been
repeatedly proven to destroy men's lives
at will is absolutely what about a woman
who was raped back in 1988 to the police
then she then the man should face
absolutely complete Justice
did you understand that when that clip
appears on tick tock as a clip and all
right that's a clip completely okay but
it's still something came out of your
mouth do you accept that when that
appears on Tick Tock a lot of young
maybe not as smart as you young men
right impressionable teenagers we'll
read that and go what's he saying is he
saying that rape doesn't exist no I
completely I'm not going to sit here as
a professional and say that I can't be
taken out of context what I will say is
that one small sentence you've taken was
from a one hour video where I explained
that of course rape is disgusting of
course everybody should be punished for
their crimes regardless of when they
happen but people are not perfect male
and female and if you give women the
opportunity to destroy men's lives
without evidence there's going to be a
contingent of women who will do that do
you think do you think women are the
property of men no the point why have
you said they are because I made a
religious point I said that when a man
marries a woman the woman's father walks
him down the aisle walks her down the
aisle and hands her way to the man
traditionally that's what it says in the
Bible I'm a religious person I believe
in God I live in the Muslim so you do
think that the woman becomes the men I
think she takes his last name I mean
let's watch the clip that you said about
sure so that we can get it in context
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but I've I've been
married twice as it turns out and on
both occasions I didn't believe that the
woman was being handed to me as chattel
as property and perhaps the way that
that the reason I'm asked that question
repeatedly and I'm asked in a loaded way
so would you rephrase what you said
there now what that's that's an
interesting point about phrasing the way
I would say things before I was famous I
have to take personal responsibility and
accept right that if I make a video that
500 people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that 5 million people see
and one percent of Vietnam so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's property she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has said
it herself right so she she's still a
sovereign individual she's absolutely
property means that the husband owns
your sister listen my friend if you want
to argue about this we need to go back
to the Bible to the Quran you need to
argue with religious no no I'm not
talking about any I think it's a Bible
of Quran that's what it says no no I'm
asking you what you think I think that
if a woman marries a man and she decides
to take his last name that they have
different roles and responsibilities
within that marriage and I believe that
that's not the question she's had I
believe
like a politician the father hands her
to the man Robert don't be a politician
because I think you're a straight talker
right you keep telling me you're
straight talk I think my sister is her
husband's property do you regret saying
it like that I I understand that with my
newfound Fame perhaps it could be
phrased differently however I still
believe that a woman is given to the man
in marriage that's what I believe yeah
but not as property now the property is
the word that other people use the
question but as a an equal partner in a
loving Union that's what marriage
actually means it doesn't mean
given to you as a bit of Chapel I agreed
so why say it but that's the way that
people ask me the question people say to
me they ask me you can't blame people
for asking you questions surely if you
want to be accountable for what you said
you've got to own your responses don't
blame the question I own the response
let me ask you a question now and you
say something and then say well I shall
blame you for I understand Pierce peers
I understand I believe the woman is
given to the man I believe she's given
away by the father I believe she belongs
to the man so you do belong
fundamentally right so fundamentally you
do believe that a woman becomes a man's
property I believe she belongs to the
man in marriage correct right
oh you see that to me is misogyny and
you're entitled to your opinion right
but do you want do you not understand
why people think it is misogyny I
understand why some people can be very
offended by what I say what they do is
they take a point like that and they
ignore all the other points I make the
other way right that's why that's why
I've repeatedly asked you about that
line to see if you've changed your
position but the reality is you haven't
it's not about changing positions I'm a
full-grown adult and I stick by the
things I say and I'm responsible for
them which by the way is fine absolutely
so what you did say at the start of this
little exchange you said you know I
wouldn't maybe say things the same way
now that I did before I was famous and
yet actually you've doubled that it's
exactly the same thing on certain points
so that is what you believe that's my
point yes I'm trying to work out look I
don't know you we've just met right yeah
I'm trying to work out who Andrew Tate
is and what you actually believe I don't
want to twist anything at all doesn't
maybe make it very very clear to the
camera I believe a woman is given to the
man in marriage but a man doesn't own a
woman it's not no it's honestly
literally buy them as a slave well
obviously we're not talking about that
we're talking about religious biblical
marriage we're talking about something
else yeah but I'm a Christian I don't
believe that I I I I own my wife do you
believe your wife was given away to you
when she took her last night I believe
that there is a process where a father
traditionally walks his daughter down
the aisle and hands his daughter to this
man and they stand there and become a
union of two loving people in a
partnership no there's no ownership
involved you're a smart guy right
there's no denying that you're a smart
you're a good talker I've seen a lot of
the stuff but when you what what I don't
think you quite fully understand no I
understand when young impressionable
people I understand you are not as smart
see things like I think my sister is a
husband's property yes and you've just
reaffirmed that that belief they think
that they have the right to own women I
understand that very well Pierce that's
why people think you're a massage
completely I understand all of this very
well which is why when you're saying I
was backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret though over the way you phrase
this stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds can be taken out of
context you went on to say about
authority over women if I have a
responsibility over I must have a degree
of authority yeah for the same reason if
I have responsibility over and people
are going to lose their mind it's an
example an energy responsibility over a
child I have to have some Authority so
you believe as part of your ownership or
your property of of the woman you have
authority over her no I believe if you
ever that's what you said I believe
you've ever responsibility over
something you have to have a degree of
authority who can't be responsible yeah
but Authority means again that you're
the boss the point
okay if you'll please let me finish at
this point the point I was trying to
make was talking about the safety of a
woman she was walking alone at night and
I was saying well I wouldn't let my
woman walk alone at night and they said
well you're not in charge of her you
don't get to decide what she does I say
I understand but if I'm responsible for
her safety and I'm the person who's
burdened with making sure she is safe I
have to have the authority to say don't
put yourself in unsafe situations the
two things are linked well you know
you're an authority you have the you can
absolutely have the right to say to the
woman you're with I don't think you
should but ultimately if she decides
that I can't force her right so
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies I have
the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible for that's not what
Authority means I I accept that you use
the analogy of responsibility for a
child my friend these are these are very
these are actually really important
things they're important things but you
introduce you introduce you interrupt me
every five seconds so it's hard for me
to actually explain my point the point
I'm making here is very simple you have
children and you're responsible for
their safety so you're going to have
authority to say don't go out at night
perhaps because you want them to be safe
you have legal Authority you have a
legal Authority yeah legal Authority I'm
saying that if I had a woman and the
question where you've raised a sound
bite from I was asked about protecting a
woman making sure she's safe and I would
say I wouldn't want her to go out at
night on her own because I'm responsible
for her safety and someone said well you
don't have authority over it to do that
and I said well no I can't force her to
stay inside but if she were to ask me
how do I protect myself at night I would
say well you should stay inside that's
how you should do that's I don't have an
issue with so we agree no it's the
semantics it's not semantics and this is
what I don't think you quite get why
there's a fury over what you say with
respect because the semantics point
would be we're saying the same thing in
different ways but we're not I'm saying
to you that when you say I have to have
some authority over a woman I say to you
you have no right to any authority over
a woman you do over a child if it's your
child because you are the legal
appointed guardian of that child you're
not a legally appointed guardian or
authority over your wife or female
legally appointed absolutely not I agree
however
when it comes to things like personal
response or personal safety men largely
by Society are accepted we're the
protectors and providers we can sit here
and pretend in the world we live in if
me and my wife were walking down the
street and men were to come up and try
and attack us I wouldn't be the one
fighting but we both know in reality I
would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
survive a degree of responsibility to
protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never putting herself
you wish you hadn't used the word
Authority The Authority is something
that she would give to me she would come
to me and say how do how can I make sure
that's possible but I don't interrupt
you I just want to point out that's not
what Authority means if someone gives
you can a person can get voluntary
Authority is not authoritic no but
that's the point
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety
coming up more from Andrew Tate
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored
Andrew Tate one on one
do you respect women absolutely why
wouldn't I do you think the 18 19 year
old woman are more attractive than 25
year old woman I think there's
Attractive people uh that's that's a
loaded question I don't know it's not
real is it I I can't know why I'm asking
of course I do but I can't sit here and
so the benefit of you is you don't know
why I'm asking you said this in general
this is also one of the reasons men find
youth attractive you want to block the
internet or block the internet write a
thing now the reason 18 and 19 year olds
are more attractive than 25 year olds is
because they've been through less dick
people say oh you can't say that but yes
I can a 19 year old is more attractive
than 26 year old woman and I'll tell you
why because that 26 year old has talked
to more guys been to the club more times
being effed and dumped more times more
arguments More Mess more for me to clean
up that is misogyny why because you are
encouraging a mindset about 25 year old
women that makes them sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case they
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
will be more pretty anti-25 year old
woman anti-25 or women we can argue but
not misogynistic well that's massage no
no no it's not being anti-any woman at
all is misogyny not when I'm not what
I'm saying that women are beautiful and
attractive at a certain age and saying
the ages you're saying 1899 they're more
attractive than 20 years than ageist
perhaps but misogynistic absolutely but
you just accepted it was misogyny no I
didn't you said it was Monster Sergeant
I'm telling you no it's not you don't
think if you're saying slightly hateful
things about it that's not slightly
hateful well it is you you think you you
say that to a woman's face and she's 25
it's not slightly hateful when you would
go up to 25 year old woman and tell her
exactly what I've just read why would I
walk up to a random 25 because you said
it in public it's on the internet and
it's been listened to and watched by
millions and millions of young girls
there was a large panel there was a
conversation there was hours Longs of
conversation there were feminists
attacking men for toxic masculinity and
attacking me and saying things and I
said things back which we're going to
attack but I think see I'm I so which
you've done yourself a bunch of times I
think a lot of allegations are toxic
masculinity are not toxic correct I do
think that kind of uh sentence I just
read out that that paragraph is actually
toxic if you genuinely mean that and you
say you wouldn't say it to a woman's
face but you said it in public about
women of that age I do think that's
misogynist and I think you probably do
too I don't think it's misogynistic I
understand why it can be insulting too
you wouldn't say it to a woman's face
well it depends you're making out like
I'm walking around the street going up
to random 25. you're doing it to tens of
millions of people online there's no
difference not at all we're discussing a
topic we were discussing the ideal age
of a man should should young boys right
in their teens are you comfortable that
they would have that mindset be honest I
think that young boys in their teens
lack life experience they lack nuance
and they need to be very very careful
what they're digesting online whether
it's my content or anybody else's we
agree about a lot of things but when I
read that kind of thing I'm like
I just how much of that is you how much
of that is some ACT do you regret saying
stuff like this I don't actually do you
see it as weakness to admit you
shouldn't have said something like that
no I don't live with regret I think
what's happened is that like I said long
format content arguments with feminists
arguments with the toxic masculine crowd
arguments with the left and they're
going to take a small clip small
sentence from hours and I'm going to try
and paint me and I'm not left or right I
don't know what you are Pierce exactly
that's my point that's my point and I
understand and and you're doing exactly
as I knew would happen on this interview
which is because you're a busy man
you're not going to watch hours and
hours and hours of video actually I
haven't watched thousand hours of video
and I'm going to come to the stuff where
I agree with you and I'm going to come
to the stuff about your censorship which
I have issues with so this is It's a
Long interview right sure I just thought
off the top you said to me and you were
quite bold about it well go on and let's
go through this and you and you should
keep going I will sit here and stand by
what I said I believe that oh man on
that I just read to you that yeah do you
wish you hadn't said that
I understand how it's been misconstrued
I understand how it's been weaponized
against me do I regret it because it's
been weaponized and used against me well
that's slightly annoying did I that's
not why did I at the time mean what I
said and in the context of the
conversation which obviously you you're
not familiar with and the people at home
are not familiar with no I meant what I
said the 25 year old women have just
talked to more guys been to the club
more times being effed and dumped more
times more arguments More Mess more for
me to clean up well there's a whole much
there's a whole bunch of context and
conversation around that that's been
missed and I don't think I'm missing
much context well I I encourage people
who are interested to go watch it a bit
I mean I've just read out three
sentences on the bounce there I don't
think there's any context I'm missing I
mean you'll you've made it pretty clear
what you think about the difference
between 18 and 90 year old women I
wasn't talking about myself even I was
explaining I was talking with a Muslim
guy who was on the panel and he was
explaining how youth is very valid
valued in most parts of the world and
why Virginia is valued in both parts of
the world the feminists were arguing
against it the conversation has been
misunderstood they've taken this clip of
it and it's been weaponized and used
against me I understand that is because
I'm now the most famous Google person on
the planet it's inconvenient sure but
I'm definitely not a danger to women in
any regard I date women 25 26 27 years
old all the time none of them are
offended by the thing I don't think
you're a danger to women I think I think
the danger if it concerns you the danger
is the influence you have on young men
to have this kind of mindset about women
and that's really where I'm trying to
get to what you really believe and how
much you've just shot off because you
think it's like entertaining and you
haven't really given it much thought and
whether now you're a bit older and
you've had all the Fallout where the
part of you is thinking actually if I
had as Joe Rogan says if you hadn't said
stuff like this you'd probably still
been on these platforms you'd be
massively more popular massively more
famous massively richer so I'm really
just trying to get to on the blatantly
misogynist stuff do you just wish you
hadn't said it with great power comes
great responsibility it was certainly
said before the great power came it's
inconvenient to a degree however like I
said at the time with the context of the
conversation I know that I'm not saying
things which I believe to be detrimental
to the world however they've been
misconstrued and they've been
misunderstood if a 25 year old woman was
watching this would you say I'm sorry
for saying that oh I wouldn't want
anyone to be offended by anything I say
but I say things but I say things that
offend and this is the thing that's
interesting Pierce please let me finish
are you again like a politician but hang
on you could say I'm interrupting you do
but you're answering a different
question to the one I asked you so as an
interviewer okay sure okay sure okay you
accept that that's exactly okay so again
my point is simply if a 26 year old
woman is watching this and has heard
those comments would you just say to her
look I'm sorry I shouldn't have said
that no I won't I will say that I am
sorry that that offends you however
there's a large contention of the world
it doesn't mean you're sorry no I'm not
sorry that's the point I'm making I'm
sorry if that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
that believed that and I was mediating
for a conversation parts of the world
that believed that about 26 year old
women are parts of the world where women
are not allowed out on their own that's
your that's a conversation you have to
wear full burkas well that's a
conversation they're not allowed to
drive cars that's nothing to do with it
but is that the kind of world for a
woman I was mediating a conversation I'm
asking you what you think I I don't live
in a country where that happens you're
using that is the excuse for why you're
not sorry for saying it there are parts
of the world but this is fine my
question to you is well do you think
it's fine I don't think it's fine I live
in a world where you don't think it's
fine my the reason this isn't that hard
Andrew you can simply say beers you know
what with the benefit of hindsight I
wish I hadn't said it like that and if a
26 year old woman's watching I'm sorry I
said that because that actually is
blatantly misogynist and even though
that's the view held by other parts of
the world it's not of you I share now I
would respect you more if you said that
yeah and if you try and say Well it said
in other parts of the world so I'm not
sorry I think that doesn't tell me what
you think then you need to understand
why my content existed in the first
place my content existed because I tried
my very hardest to be an absolute not a
realist especially with uncomfortable
truths I was pointing out that very
uncomfortable is that a truth it's an
uncomfortable truth in many parts of the
world it's not a truth that I'm happy
about it's not true no hang on you're
doing it again what do you mean that's a
truth in other parts of the world that's
what you said it's not you're not
talking about another part of the world
you're talking about what you believe is
the difference between 18 and 90 year
olds and 26 year olds who I was talking
about your belief I was talking about
what the people on the panel believe the
difference is
so what do you think the difference is I
think the difference is age what's the
difference though well then 26 year olds
older than the 19 year old and so you
stand by what you said about talking to
the guys been to the club long times
been after dump more times why do you
believe that or not no there's plenty of
26 year old women who have been with one
man or a virgin of course so you don't
believe that I don't think that the age
is the only thing that's going to
decipher well how many men and women I
said we don't actually believe what
you're saying just say sorry it's not
about not believing what I'm saying it's
about you understanding that there's
large conversations going on you were
saying what you think
is is I I feel like you're trying to pin
me down if it's not what you believe
just say I don't believe that
what part wouldn't I believe well you
tell me which part you don't believe
there's the sentence which part would
you now say you don't believe
I believe that 25 year old women perhaps
have had because they've been alive
longer maybe have had more Partners but
I don't believe that makes them a bad
person right but you understand that the
way you phrased it makes every 25 I
understand you're a bad person no I
don't think so of course you do not
stupid now come on peers Angie you're
not stupid you know what that sounds
like to any 25 26 year old woman
completely and you're right so you have
maligned every 25 26 year old woman with
that statement and I'm simply asking you
to all those who are not of the type of
women that you've described it are you
sorry I don't want anybody to be
offended by anything I say I want to be
a positive force in the world I don't
want anybody to hear what I say and make
them feel bad about themselves I want
all people to live righteous and good
whether they're male or female
coming up more from Andrew Tate
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one
on one
if you've ever been in love yeah how
many times plenty I believe in love
between men and women I'm a real love
you know yeah I believe how many times
would you say let's say 10 I mean I've
been in love and I certainly believe
that men and women when they work
together is the most beautiful force on
the planet I believe in family I believe
in children I believe in why are you
single I'm not single well you're not
married that's what I mean well if I was
married the last thing I would do is
advertise it to the feral Psychopaths on
the internet so I'm not feral psych
about well like you called me a friend
earlier it can be debated peers but the
point the point but the point I'm making
as a whole is that do you want to get
married no but this is but we have to we
house all feed into each other peers I'm
talking about protect the whole question
no but I'm talking about protecting and
providing for a woman I'm talking about
a man being responsible for her safety I
understand so of course I believe in men
and women of course I believe in love of
course I believe in marriage of course I
believe in family the idea that I don't
believe in the idea that I don't believe
in these things if you believed it I
asked you if you're going to get married
one day absolutely you'd like to if I'm
not married already I would I will be
married one day if I'm not well you
might be secretly married I could be
married correct why would you not tell
me either way why would I advertise to
the feral Psychopaths of the world who
have tried their very best to destroy me
for an opinion about my private life and
the things that are most sacred to me
wow I think if you said you were married
everyone would hate you I don't like
people hate me it's about me
understanding that I'm a hard target but
I am very very protective of the people
I care about right but you believe in
the concept of marriage completely
that's what we were talking about the
whole time what do you think we talked
about a man giving a woman away I
believe in marriage more than anybody I
believe in marriage and no please I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect the
woman and provide for her so he needs to
make sure that she's safe he needs a
degree of authority I have no problem
with no but no you but people do have a
problem with it sorry and that's the
word we're in now I'm over here sure I
don't have a problem with what you just
said here's where my problem comes right
there are a lot of clips of you floating
around on the internet as you know one
of them has you saying bang out the
machete boom in her face Ripper by the
neck shut up [ __ ] in another you say
slap slap grab choke shut up [ __ ] sex
when people see those clips and here you
say those things agree well I don't
think that
it's not hard to misunderstand it it is
you might say that it's consensual other
people would say whether it's consensual
or not that's a very ugly way to talk
about women completely now that's
hitting them with machetes no you watch
the whole video it's a girl coming at me
with a machete and me saying here slap
the machete out of her hand she's
attacking me so you don't understand
this is the exact point no people don't
watch them in full and this is actually
what's interesting and please don't
interrupt me on this point social media
has changed in Modern Times YouTube five
years ago was five six seven eight
minute long videos now we have Tick Tock
10 seconds 15 seconds 20 seconds YouTube
shorts Instagram stories now anything
you produce as long form is cut down to
very very short form they're interested
in clicks they're interested in
engagements they find the most they find
the most controversial Clips they can on
purpose you benefited from all that
everybody benefits from social media
views yes do you yo was it the Hustler
what is it I had an online school cool
houses University right and their whole
job was to promote your Clips Matthew
rich and famous so you've benefited from
this system the one you now profess to
hate you benefited from I never said I
hate it they didn't like the best of
them I never said I hated it I'm saying
what happened I don't hate it I don't
hate social media I think it's a very
powerful force I don't hate the social
media I'm saying that is I think you can
talk look you can talk to girlfriends of
yours
um maybe a secret wife I don't know or
two or two maybe you've got ten wise
that's your business I don't care right
my and the thing is I don't care what
you do in private if you're consensual
between you and another woman you can do
what you like right it's your life I
believe in freedom and liberty it's when
you said in public it's the influence
that this kind of thing has on young men
I agree right and I speak to someone
with three sons right it's well by the
way they're intrigued by you they're
fascinated right you're you're a big
thing in that world of tick tock and so
on so they all are aware of you and what
you say so they're all looking And when
they see things like the machete thing I
get the context because I'm a 57 year
old guy who's been around the block a
bit and I can get what you've said and
you're responding to a particular
scenario which you'd created where a
woman but it can be misunderstood I
understand so my point to you is given
that you know it can be misunderstood do
you regret saying things like this on
camera where it can be disseminated by
less intelligent young males who think
that is actually what they should be
doing to women and finally we get to the
point of the issue which is the point I
tried to make at the very beginning when
I made a video before I was famous they
got 500 abuse me being concerned that
one percent of people will misunderstand
it was not relevant we're not you start
getting five million views of video 50
million views of video one percent of
people misunderstanding doesn't change
no it doesn't but it becomes a much
larger problem and so with great Fame
that's true comes great responsibility
right so I agree would I now I'm famous
do I say things the same way as I did
back before I was famous absolutely not
right as neither would you or nearly any
other famous person on the planet once
you become famous you have to be a lot
more careful with how you say things I
understand so my logical follow-up to
that remains do you regret them saying
it the way you said it I can't live in
regret by saying something before I was
famous on a camera which barely anybody
watched and then I became famous
afterwards that would be a very asinine
way to view the world you can't live and
you stand by all those I can't live in
regret because I didn't know I was gonna
become the most famous man on the planet
you see one of the problems that people
have with you is that
they think you have a malevolent
influence on young people this was the
excuse that was put out by the big Tech
Excuse excuse being the key word well it
may be actually you know I I
intrinsically I have a problem with
censorship I don't think Donald Trump
should be banned from Twitter for
example because the Ayatollah of Iran
remains on Twitter and other social
media platforms and whatever I think of
you you're not the Ayatollah of Iran
right so there's there's a to me there's
got to be perspective here and I don't
understand the inconsistency by what
companies like Twitter how they treat
the the leader of Iran and someone like
you seems to be in a much more Draconian
on people like you yeah than they are
with people who perhaps should not be
allowed platforms
um but generally I don't really agree
with no platforming people yeah but I
think what's interesting talking to you
is it seems to me like you have gone on
a bit of a journey of self-awareness
about the impact of some of the stuff
you said in the past and you have said
you wouldn't say it again in the same
way now you may not want to express
regret for that but it shows me that the
very least you have evolved to somebody
who recognizes that these can be quite
damaging in the way that you said them
completely as a professional and as an
adult it would be stupid for me to sit
here and say that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet my words do not
have more impact than they did before
the final part of my Institute interview
with Andrew Tate
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one
on one
you talk about people don't want to see
men dressed up in dresses I transgender
that's not exactly what I said what did
you say I said the reason I am so
popular and I'm so famous is that
there's a large contingent of men who
don't want to wear makeup who still want
to make money go to the gym be strong
drive a fast car be traditionally
masculine and don't want to be shamed
for that and they don't want to be
called toxic for that that is the reason
I'm so massively famous that is what do
you think of transgender people that's
nothing to do with me I'm not
transgender and I don't understand the
issue like they do when they attacked me
they lump a whole bunch of things in
together they say misogynistic racist
transphobic they just put them all
together a mixed race by the way I don't
know where they get these they just get
these buzzwords
I completely agree it's crazy and I've
had the same thing done to me okay and
I'm not calling you anything I'm asking
you what you personally believe you are
I it's not an issue I discuss what I do
discuss is that you support transgender
people I I support individual liberty
I'm a Libertarian so you support
transgender people sure what do you
believe about depression do you believe
depression is a real thing I believe
that feeling depressed is real I don't
believe depression as a clinical disease
is real now really correct you don't
believe people can be clearly depressed
I think PTSD is very real I've
unfortunately I have some friends who
suffer from that and I know that feeling
depressed is real I believe that the
number one power you have against these
things are taking trying to take control
of your own mind and affecting your own
life I've lived a very difficult life
and I know people who have that the
things that made them feel better is
when they woke up and said you know what
I'm not going to allow this to damage me
anymore I'm going to take responsibility
I'm going to get up and I'm going to
fight this as hard as I can and by the
way on that I agree so my favorite
speech is the Rocky Balboa okay so then
we agree no we didn't it's we don't
agree Pierce you don't hang on you've
got to let me sure interject when I
don't agree with you right where I don't
agree did is that there's no such thing
as clinical depression there absolutely
is well it's a proven scientific medical
reality there's a different argument
about have we gone a bit too soft right
in schools and all the rest of it
absolutely yeah well I think some people
moan and whine too much about their lot
in life definitely okay are we a
victimhood society 100 okay is there
such a thing as clinical depression
absolutely so my argument is that if you
actually bracket everybody who's not
politically depressed and doesn't have
the genuine medical condition then
actually if millions of people are
deemed to have depression the ones who
really need the help don't get it well
that's my point well that can that that
I would agree with you're right I think
it's certainly overused terms of the
research doesn't think no I don't Andrew
You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with you I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts I'm never going to die
because I don't believe in it it's
ridiculous perhaps but if it allows me
to live a life where I feel happy again
this is that little area where you lose
me no I don't lose you because somebody
with your following so thousands of
people the thousands of people who have
emailed me saying my doctor told me I
was clinically depressed and it's the
disease that I have got in my brain and
I can't be fixed and I started listening
to you and I realized that that's not
the case and I can fix my own life and
you're the only person who has ever
helped me thousands of people that email
me that email if you think you are
single-handedly curing people of
clinical depression you are living in
Cloud curriculum I am reading the emails
of people who I have Curative clinical
depression you're reading emails from
people who have believed you when you
say there isn't such a thing and they've
probably never been diagnosed clinical
depressed they just want to go along
with what Andrew dates says I don't
think so and I think your view of that
is that view is dangerous I I respect
that you think my view is dangerous and
I respect you have the right to view
that to think that I think that clinical
depression I actually agree do is
massively over diagnosed I've already
said that PTSD is a very real thing I've
already said I didn't no hang on okay
again you misquoted me I I did not say
clinical depression is massively over
diagnosed I said that people who claim
to be depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words there are
a lot of people who just have a bad day
yeah and declare I've got depression
yeah and I I say well have you been to a
doctor have you been clinically
diagnosed if you have and you have
clinical depression that's one thing but
if you haven't we could probably work on
some mental strength and resilience
skills with it but a clinically
depressed person has a an absolutely
proven medical condition that is beyond
their control not according to me and
many others my friend well look what do
you know about it honestly sure you're a
guy on the make he's done very well for
himself spouting stuff off much of which
I agree with as you've seen in the
interview uh but some of which is
ludicrous and that's one of them it's
not ludicrous it is it's not if you said
to me we're in a victimhood society has
got to stop I'm with you okay at the
moment you try and deny clinical
depression I believe feeling depressed
is real I do not believe it's a disease
that you catch from the sky and you
cannot affect I believe that no matter
what happens I believe you have control
of your own mind and you can fight
against it fine good so we agree no we
don't yes we do no we don't fears are on
my side you're afraid of being canceled
along with me I said to you from the
start that's all I agree with a lot of
what you say completely so I thought I'm
taking you to task over the stuff I
don't agree with sure and I'm just not
sure you understand why it's wrong which
is in itself quite revealing let me talk
to you about Alex let me talk to you
about Alex Jones right who I have a bit
of history with each other to get me
deported from the United States did he
yeah what is your view of Alex Jones I
think that Alex Jones is a sovereign
individual who very much like the Rabid
left deserves a chance to speak on his
points of view I think that the truth on
issues is usually somewhere in the
middle between two extremes and I think
you think Sandy Hook was staged I don't
know anything about San Diego really you
know he's just been sued by the families
millions and millions I have no idea you
don't think about it no so why would you
support someone in public you know
nothing about the most infamous when
have I supported him in public you have
supported him in public I don't know
Sandy Hook I don't know and you know
what it was it was a mass shooting of
school children okay but to sit and and
he's actually no no let's stop for a
second please don't interrupt me
the here's why you're I know why you're
good at your job first you interrupt
people a lot which is good it's a good
skill and then here you go prove me
right but here's the timing is good
here's exactly what I do I only
interrupt people like you when you
either
refused to answer the question or answer
a completely different one sure and I
want to remind you of what the question
was found or when you misquote me back
which you've done repeatedly through the
interview where you say you see peers
you agree with me and the viewer who's
been watching will go no he didn't cool
no problem the other thing you do is you
try and set these traps like now so
you're saying what's the Trap you think
I'm saying you're saying that I agree
with every single point of view a man
has I literally didn't say that you're
saying well you support Alex Jones why
don't you misquote me because you're
saying you support Alex Jones and you
said he you've been on his podcast and
he said this
I don't know what do you think about
exchange I don't know everything he said
what do you think of him I think I think
on his podcast he was cordial I think he
was professional on his podcast I've
also done podcasts with rabid leftists
and and people who openly hate me Alex
Jones said that Sandy Hook didn't happen
it was staged by actors okay this
compounded the appalling grief of the
families of those poor 20 children okay
who were gunned to Pieces by a lunatic
with an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle they
were already Greek stricken beyond
belief and this guy pulled petrol onto
that grief quite deliberately to make a
huge amount of money from his Infowars
fake news [ __ ] and as a result a lot
of the families have now sued him and
they've won and he's gonna have to pay
back tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars in Damages to these families and
quite right it won't do anything about
the pain he calls them some of them
actually have people turn up outside
their houses with guns because Alex
Jones had told them that these parents
were making it all up they were all
staged actors it was all run by the
government so I simply say to you now
I've told you that what is your view of
Alex Jones
I don't see why any of that has to do
with me I I it's very interesting I've
done the guys podcast I know him well he
was professional and courteous to me
when I meet somebody and they show me
respect I show them back respect that's
what I do as I dig with you you respect
him if somebody shows me respect and his
courteous to me I'm curious facts had a
podcast would you go on it
sure you would great I've done a bunch
of podcasts with people who are
advocating for things okay that I do not
agree with on every single level in fact
most of my podcasts are me disagreeing
with people so it's completely crazy
that you're trying to lump me in without
it that's cheap you are completely
misconstruing the point of what I'm
saying I think deliberately no no what
you're trying is a cheap trick and I'm
just making it clear I'm just curious
where you're like where your moral line
is it's a cheap trick is your moral life
I disagree with the points of view with
the majority of the people I do podcasts
with so it's a very cheap trick you're
trying here so people invent vile things
to make themselves rich off the back of
families of little kids who've been
blown to pieces with a machine gun
or a semi-automatic version of a machine
gun I think that is actually a line I
would I wouldn't cross I wouldn't be
happy to go on someone's podcast when
they've been responsible for doing that
it's not about political views or
differences of opinion over facts it's
about somebody deliberately inventing a
pack of lies to compound the grief of
families and I just I'm curious you
don't think you have any need to go down
any kind of moral quandary about people
like that before you continue to allow
them to use you for their own promotion
he didn't use me he didn't use me why is
he on the podcast because we disagreed
and discussed points like we're doing
with you right now did you call him out
on that are you using me we didn't
discuss that I'm not using I'm giving
you a platform most people aren't giving
you right now to show the world who you
really are fantastic so neither of us
are using each other I'm here on your
show I'm providing you with content
you're giving me a platform and nobody's
using each other it's mutual we don't
agree on a whole bunch of issues it's
fine and here we are I think we've had a
robust exchange do you identify as a
feminist I think that women and men and
are fantastic both of us are fantastic I
think women reproduce I think women need
to be respected protected provided for I
think that modern feminism is kind of
hard for me to even truly what do you
think it means what is feminism I think
that the idea of feminism is that men
and women are equal uh under the law and
do you believe that completely we should
be treated completely yeah but we are
equal under the law wouldn't you agree
uh not really I think there are still
some issues in the world where I mean
certainly in workplace the gender pay
Gap remains uh they're not treated
equally in most cases women well that
can be discussed the gender pay Gap I
think that's already been discussed at
length I think that there's actually
women should go to work I think women
should work completely I do believe that
the most in my personal view the most
important and respectful thing a woman
can do is become a mother I think that
having children is a beautiful thing
chipmunk young men though all aspire to
be like you should young men aspire to
work very hard have no criminal record
become multi-millionaires protect and
provide for the women close to them uh
be Sovereign so they can stand up and
have their own points of view in face of
cancellation be able to not be mentally
intimidated when they go on national TV
and there's traps set up for them yeah I
believe that confident strong men who
stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
a good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Nas twerk
talking on the devil on music videos
which our children are digesting you
have uh drillar is singing about
stabbing people to death in the middle
of a knife crime epidemic you have rabid
uh Psychopaths on whether the right or
the left announcing violence on the
other side I think if you're honest with
yourself yeah yeah that you can see why
people found a lot of the stuff you've
said
problematic and misogynist and I think
you recognized you wouldn't express
yourself in that way again because
you've understood that it caused a lot
of harm and that's really really what I
wanted to get to today was an
acknowledgment by you that these things
clearly
were said in the wrong way created the
wrong impression if you didn't mean them
the way you intended them and can
therefore have a malevolent influence
when you have a huge following yeah when
you have a huge following you certainly
have to be a lot more careful about how
you get certain points across that's
absolutely a fact Andrew I appreciate
you coming all the way from Romania
thank you it's been an interesting
conversation and I thank you for having
it cheers man well that's it for me
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight show for Tool radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking
um that remain had won and at half past
two quarter three after Nigel farage had
already said he'd lost it turned out he
hadn't lost and it turned out we were
leaving the European Union so that was
quite a shocker
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams
Attorney MP has been sacked from
government with immediate effect after a
complaint of serious misconduct at the
Conservative Party Conference Connor
Burns who's been the MP for Bournemouth
West since 2010 has also had the party
whip suspended Liz truss says ministers
must maintain high standards of behavior
a man armed with a knife has been shot
dead by police in Derby armed officers
responded to reports of a knife man in a
police station car park at around 10
o'clock this morning and the man died in
hospital from his injuries and it's
Liverpool calling as the city has been
chosen as the official host of the 2023
Eurovision song contest the city beat
off competition from Glasgow as the UK
hosts the contest in place of this
year's winners Ukraine that's all for
now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
foreign